and finally time to play my wife's
favorite game how would I cheat on my
wife with feel free to play along at
home silently in your head all right
here we got 400 Margot Robbie very
talented very beautiful but my mom's
name is Margot and I would not cheat on
my wife with my mom and to be clear this
is all hypothetical I'm aware these
women would not want to have sex with me
I mean most likely I have a better
chance than most of you
Rihanna yes yes I would but only once
and then I would tell my wife
it was Rihanna she'd say it's Rihanna
and I'd like felt the same Jason Momoa
that's a hard no okay not slumming at
the DC Universe Marvel for life Emily
Ratajkowski
yeah if she I ever got together I would
recommend making me the lead suspect in
my wife's disappearance because I would
100% gone girl my wife
Selena Gomez I'm not gonna do that to
Pete Davidson that's the wrong dumb pop
star my dad still no she has a kid face
it's unsettling Michael B Jordan now I
do think he is one of the best-looking
humans alive and we would have beautiful
babies but I think I probably wanted to
keep him in the friend zone but cheating
doesn't have to be just intercourse
they're gonna be texting kissing bondage
it all counts Elizabeth Olsen no even
though she is by far the prettiest Olsen
most talented goes to Carolina Panthers
tight end Greg Olson there's also no
only cuz he's not playing right now
Aubrey Plaza seems like a lateral move
but sure Megan Markel the Duchess of
Sussex so if I cheat with her that puts
me in line to be the King of England
that's interesting but no no only worse
than a British accents is like when
American girls move over there and then
they start picking up a fake British
accent oh that's not gonna fly Oprah not
powerful enough
call me when you're president more that
Lana coach lame kid why not
it'd be like hooking up with myself if I
ate every single meal at Panda Express
Melania Trump
FLOTUS seems pretty used to the world of
cheating
but like the president I too would
prefer to sleep with Ivanka